before we get going with our discussion
of inference methods it is worth looking
at the big picture for some perspective
so far we have concentrated on ways to
analyze probability models this part of
the picture if our model has been
selected in a careful way then it should
also be relevant to the real world and
help us make predictions or decisions
but how do we know that this is the case
this is why we need to look at data that
are generated by the real world and then
use these to come up with the model this
is what the field of inference and
statistics is all about this field has
undergone a radical transformation in
recent years
I will exaggerate a little but in the
past as the distinction might be called
to look at problems such as this one
you're given data on a few patients and
you need to figure out whether a certain
treatment is effective or not but today
as the distinction lives in a dreamland
there are tones of data that are
generated everywhere these allow us to
build quite detailed large models
involving thousands of parameters and we
do have the computational power to do
all that in this landscape the
opportunities for a statistician are
endless so let me give you a small
representative sample in a somewhat
traditional setting one designs a data
collection method and then uses these
data to make a simple prediction this is
the case for example in polling where
the purpose is to predict the outcome of
an election another field is marketing
and advertising where the situation is
somewhat similar except now we want to
make predictions not for a population as
a whole but for each individual consumer
and the particular application has to do
with so-called recommendation systems
you collect ratings that people give to
movies as in a famous competition that
was announced by Netflix so you have
data for
every movie and the people who have
watched them you make a note of what
rating that person gave to a particular
movie and now after you collect huge
amounts of data of this kind you try to
use this information to yes whether for
example this person is interested in
this particular movie or not this is a
quite difficult problem a quite
complicated one and it gave the
community an opportunity to develop
fancier and fancier combinations of
methods in order to come up with good
predictions of unknown entries in this
table another field is of course finance
the markets are truly uncertain and
there are quite complete historical data
lots of them how do we use these data to
make predictions coming now to the
Natural Sciences a revolution has been
taking place in the life sciences there
are tons of genomic data to be processed
to find out what combination of genes
causes what disease or we may want to
find out the details of the chemical
reactions inside the living cell and
there is an upcoming new frontier in
neuroscience where there will be vast
amounts of data that will be generated
these will consist of brain measurements
of measurements of what each neuron is
doing and hopefully these will lead us
one day to finding out what the brain
really does and how it works in the
sciences the list is endless it goes on
and on in modeling climate and the
environment scientists are using huge
models these days which they try to
calibrate using lots of available data
and in physics as well scientists use
fancy inference methods trying to find
needles in a haystack like rare
particles or remote planets
finally engineering is a fight against
noise engineers try to make devices that
will work in uncertain environments the
field of signal processing is a prime
example where the generic question is to
recover the content of a signal for
example the content of a radio
transmission when a signal is received
after it gets corrupted by noise I could
go on and on for hours generating lists
of this kind but we have to stop
somewhere the bottom line is that the
opportunities and the needs are vast for
this reason we will look into the core
methodologies that come into play
fortunately for us the fundamental
concepts and approaches turn out to be
the same independent of the particular
application